foreign
[Music]
the first season of Loki already saw the
introduction of a variant of King the
Conqueror the mcu's new super villain in
Ant-Man the WASP quantumania he now made
his official villain debut however it
will still take a while before he faces
all the superheroes in the next Avengers
movie but thanks to the latest MCU posts
we can already reveal some things
regarding the cast and plot of Avengers
the Kang Dynasty so in order to spare
you the time-consuming research we have
taken a look at all the available
information and summarized it for you in
this video please note however that
there may be some spoilers for the older
MCU releases and in particular for the
new Ant-Man movie
the main story about Kang will
definitely be set several years in the
future the movie will be released
towards the end of phase six and we are
barely at the beginning of phase five
before the new Avengers movie comes out
several other Heroes and anti-heroes
will be introduced into the MCU so we
can still look forward to various movies
with new characters above all the big
Project's Thunderbolts and Fantastic
Four will introduce a few new characters
that will certainly be of importance for
The Avengers storyline after Iron Man's
death and Steve Rogers well-deserved
retirement it's not hard to imagine that
the Fantastic Four could take on a major
role in The Avengers in the future the
sequel Shang Chi 2 might also be
exciting for this project as its
director Destin Daniel will also
direct Avengers the Kang Dynasty there
are already early theories that Kang
originally created the rings of Shang
Chi according to these theories a
variant of him is said to have left the
rings on Earth up to now these are mere
speculations however
the pivotal figure of the film will for
sure be Nathaniel Richards also known as
Kenny the Conqueror at the moment the
main villain is perhaps the only
character that has been fully confirmed
he will of course still be played by
Jonathan Majors the most interesting
question is which variants will we
encounter in King Dynasty and the
credits of Ant-Man and the WASP
quantumania we were already able to see
the Council of kangs who have summoned
all the other variants the three
variants are probably Rama taught
immortus and also a version of scarlet
Centurion that is visually different
from the comic book original all three
are very powerful versions of Kang and
are sure to play key roles in Avengers 5
as well
another name we can currently find among
the cast is that of tenacuerto as King
Namor as we saw at the end of black
panther 2 wakanda forever he is still
plotting a war against the surface world
to what extent this will go along with
the story of Kang in particular though
is not clear at this point but clearly
his story is not over until the release
of The Avengers movie
who of the former Avengers will be part
of the movie is still unclear it is not
known whether there will be an epic
reunion of all superheroes against Kang
as an end game or whether the Avengers
will first have to deal with him
individually at least Ant-Man has
already fought Kang once so it seems
logical for Paul Rudd to be back every
Avengers team also requires a Captain
America who is already being introduced
to the MCU in the form of former Falcon
Sam Wilson in 2024 Anthony Mackey will
also get to star in his first solo film
in his new role with Captain America 4
New World Order whether Captain Marvel
would be part of it is questionable for
the time being she is well occupied in
the secret Invasion series The Guardians
will also probably no longer play a
major role director James Gunn is done
working for Marvel after Guardians of
the Galaxy 3 and it seems fairly certain
that some of the Guardians will die the
crew is therefore unlikely to show up
again also there are still many
questions regarding Thor actor Chris
Hemsworth wants to take a break from
acting for now to spend more time with
his family however he does wish for a
superhero character to have a story
brought to an end can we possibly expect
Thor's death in Avengers 5 of course
many fans are eagerly awaiting Tom
Holland as Spider-Man after it was
announced that there will be further
Standalone movies with him speculation
has recently Arisen that the young
superhero could even become the leader
of the Avengers this would obviously be
a massive character development of the
frequently overwhelmed Peter Parker at
the same time he would be following in
the footsteps of his mentor Tony Stark
AKA Iron Man which would be a nice touch
in our opinion
an apparent theory is that it will no
longer be the classic Adventures but
mainly the Young Avengers who will go
into battle against Kang the characters
to do so have also all been introduced
into the MCU the Young Avengers consist
of Kate Bishop America Chavez Tommy and
Billy maximoff Cassie Lang Eli Bradley
Kamala Khan and Riri Williams all of
these Heroes already play a larger or
smaller role in the MCU it was Cassie
who built the quantum realm radar which
ultimately led to the rediscovery and
killing of Kang so in a way she seems to
be the Catalyst for the upcoming war
against the king variants this makes it
all the more logical for her to become
part of the new Avengers the role has
also been freshly cast with Catherine
Newton so it seems that she will
definitely still play a part in the MCU
Haley steinfeld's time as Kate bishop or
the new Hawkeye should not be over after
the series what will happen to Tommy and
Billy maximoff however is still entirely
unclear it is true that we were able to
see many variations of them and Doctor
Strange in the Multiverse of Madness but
how and whether they will make it back
seems pretty obscure things are of
course different for sure Cheeto Gomez's
America Chavez Iman money is Kamala Khan
and Dominique Thorne as Riri Williams
all three have just made their movie or
series debut and will have an essential
part in future Productions what will
happen with Eli Bradley however is
something we'll probably only find out
in the new Captain America movie we
don't know yet whether Isaiah Bradley's
grandson will assume his role as the
Patriot but it would definitely fill the
gap of Captain America in the Young
Avengers if you want to learn more about
the Young Avengers feel free to check
out the original episode we did on them
looking at the Kings we've already had
the pleasure of seeing it's also
conceivable that Moon Knight will make
another appearance with ramatat we have
a variant that was already known in
ancient Egyptian mythology moreover the
first time he fought the Fantastic Four
was in the comics so they would also fit
perfectly into the new Avengers Ensemble
unfortunately nothing is yet known about
the cast of the four superheroes however
some people would certainly be pleased
about the return of John Krasinski who
already embodied the leader of the team
in Doctor Strange too
details about the plot are not available
yet however based on the diverse
information from films and series it is
possible to draw some conclusions what
is clear is that Earth 616 has become
very powerful due to the death of Kang
and Ant-Man and the WASP quantumania as
well as the plots of Doctor Strange in
the Multiverse of Madness and Spider-Man
no way home and is on the verge of time
travel and the exploration of the
Multiverse thus it has become a menace
to the Council of Kang and an invasion
of Earth is being planned surely not all
variants will join the war against Earth
as we know from Loki and Ant-Man there
are always variants that have their own
set of interest and Ambitions it is safe
to say that the three main villains will
be Rama Tut immortus and Scarlet
Centurion even without huge armies these
three are at least as capable opponents
as Thanos and will give our heroes
plenty of trouble that's why it is also
feasible that for some characters
Avengers 5 could be the last part
another Kang who was already wreaking
havoc on Earth is Dr Doom in the comics
there is also a variant of him as Kang
this sounds particularly plausible since
the new Fantastic Four movie is
scheduled to be released two months
before Kang Dynasty and could therefore
offer a perfect introduction since
Avengers 6 Secret Wars will feature the
well-known Secret Wars comic book Saga
it is also imaginable that most of the
heroes will not survive the fight
against Kang this could make a very good
transition to the Young Avengers who
then have to save Earth and especially
the Multiverse from collapsing in secret
Wars
the movie is currently still in
pre-production the release date has so
far been set for May 2nd 2025. however
as we know Disney there can always be
postponements and changes of Productions
also depending on how the other projects
perform the focus for the next Avengers
movie could change as well destined
Daniel is set to direct with the
script coming from Jeff loveness who
also penned the screenplay for the
latest Ant-Man movie sadly we are
unlikely to see first images of Avengers
the Kang Dynasty before 2024 as filming
has not yet begun
so that's all the information and Theory
surrounding Avengers 5 the Kang Dynasty
what do you think what will the new
Avengers team look like and what kind of
Kang variants can our new and former
Heroes expect let us know your thoughts
in the comments and if you like this
video please give it a thumbs up thanks
for watching
[Music]
foreign